foreign
[Music]
and welcome to the how the light gets in
Festival thank you for joining for our
debate on the unstable
what we cannot speak about we must pass
over in silence famously claimed the
philosopher Ludwig Wittgenstein in his
strictest logical philosophicals the
Centenary of which we are celebrating
this year
Wittgenstein primarily had in mind the
relationship between language and the
world and arguably the very idea of
metaphysics
yet a century after wittgenstein's
concluding remark many continue an
attempt to uncover and express the
ultimate meaning and nature of reality
using our all too human language
have we ignored wittgenstein's clear
message that we cannot express
meaningfully how language and our
theories relate to the world
are all our metaphysical descriptions
about the nature of reality simply
nonsense or was Wittgenstein wrong and
can we go on with our quest to uncover
the essential character of reality and
our relationship to it
to explore the unstable we have got
three brilliant speakers who I am
delighted to present
Joanna calena is a multi-award-winning
author who writes about existentialism
class the nature of Truth and quantum
physics her latest book Zed explores a
dystopian reality of big Tech and the
digital messing of humanity and
Technology
Hillary Lawson is a philosopher and
renowned critic of philosophical realism
best known for his theory of closure
which argues that we close the openness
of the world with our thought and
language
Ray Talis is a philosopher poet
neuroscientist and physician whose
philosophical writing has been informed
by his medical expertise
his books include aping mankind becoming
animal and his latest seeing ourselves
reclaiming Humanity from God and science
now to begin this debate I would like
each speaker to give a brief
three-minute presentation of their
thoughts on our opening question have we
ignored wittenstein's suggestion that we
cannot express meaningfully how language
and our theories relate to the world Ray
would you like to start
thank you Maria thank you very much
indeed and we begin with Wittgenstein
um he himself ironically did have a
theory initially of the relationship
between language and the world this was
his so-called picture theory of
propositions he believed that things
that you said could be about things in
the world because the things he said and
the things in the world shared some
properties
this was a so-called picture Theory
propositions but what they shared was a
logical form
you however rejected that and
acknowledged that language in fact had
many ways of relating to the world after
all there were different parts of speech
no a dog relates the world in one way
and the word the in quite another and
speech served different functions
something that was picked up by the
philosopher J.L Austin who didn't
actually entirely approve of
Wittgenstein but you some of you may be
familiar with his emphasis on uh Speech
as being the source of Acts
so much for the relationship between uh
language and the world well what about
theories relating to the world
what it seems in principle rather
unlikely there's going to be a general
theory
connecting theories with the world a
general theory about the relationship
between theories in the world but after
all different sorts of theory
and different sorts of world
I mean there are physical theories about
the physical world and the Very notion
of the physical world may be rather
naive and then there are social theories
about the social Realm
so there's unlikely to be an overall
theory about how those two relate or how
indeed they fail to relate
we also have a problem that certainly
has preoccupied me that as theories
become more General so they sort of lose
not only particularity which by
definition They Do by being General but
also content they become almost
exsanguinated
measurement for example reduces what is
out there to numbers so we end up with a
mathematical portrait of the world which
is as I said essentially exsanguinated
I mean E equals m c squared is a very
very fine equation but it's not exactly
uh as it were a good description of the
world it's hardly the description of an
enticing tourist destination
and having said that uh we can have a
distinguishing theories that seem to be
true or truer and theories that are
clearly wrong or less right
um and there are at least two criteria
for making that distinction
first of all true or true Earth theories
have much greater predictive power
and secondly true or truer theories
enable us to manipulate the world uh
directly or indirectly through artifacts
based on those theories in other words
they greatly enhance our agency
that's great Ray I'll we'll go back to
that how about you Joanna what do you
think about the question how we ignored
wittenstein's suggestion that we cannot
express meaningfully how language and
our theories relate to the world
thank you Maria
um well so I don't know who we is in the
question
um and uh of course it's referring it
has this kind of Echoes and this past
within it and this brings me to
borquez's definition of language which
is a set of symbols whose use among its
speakers assumes a shared past
um and I think that's a really
fundamental aspect of language whenever
we make a proposition it has all of
these kind of Echoes associations very
traces so
um for that reason and many others I
would ask personally for lots of angst
about language I think the question
suggests perhaps we've lost a certain
amount of angst about language
um I sort of Love angst maybe and that's
the kind of situation in literature
which is a sort of thing that I kind of
work in the Situation's very odd you
know each one of us is a unique
individual speaking a communal ancient
language we're given no choice we're
inducted into this system of murmurs and
squeaks from birth
um and it's a system that goes back to
Millennia long buried ages um and our
Consciousness co-evolves with our
acquisition of language so there's not a
kind of pristine original Self that we
can return to that can be stripped of
this language
um so we talk about language from deep
within it and with language deep within
us as well
and to use another metaphor stolen from
Bookers it's a labyrinth you could say
um which he steals from the Greeks of
course
um it's a man-made contrivance of great
power it doesn't give us a God's eye
view I don't believe by using words we
don't become deities you know words are
good but they're not that good
um also words are not enough there's
more in 15 minutes of Consciousness in
the whole of Shakespeare as Stevenson
said
um and I think a totally controlled
language a rigid propagandist language
combined thoughts and you see that in
regimes that seek to prevent things
being said or even thought so we need
unmolested language as Tony Morrison
said
um and it's very interesting about
wigenstein you could say as Ray was
saying you know early Wittgenstein
perhaps is is um angst and maybe late
Wittgenstein there's more love you know
he says that meaning is primarily use or
maybe I'm trying to now bind if it can
sign into my love angst theory of
language but I'll stop now because I'm
pushing at my destination
and Hillary have we ignored with in
science suggestion that we cannot
express meaningfully how language and
our theories relate to the world what do
you think well as Joe was saying I think
it depends on who the we is there I I
think it's certainly true that in in a
large chunk of
um the academy uh that uh that the
wittenstein conclusion that we're not
able to describe uh the relationship
between language and the world has been
ignored I think that that probably is
the case as realism is maybe the
dominant dominant story and that's
certainly not uh to have taken his
conclusion on board
um I think it's worth a slightly uh have
a slightly different version than the
way that Ray conveyed the shift in
thickenstein's position now it seems to
me that his his position where he said
we couldn't talk about the relation ship
between language in the world directly
followed from his early uh Outlook so he
set about trying to provide an account
of that relationship and certainly in my
view is is one of the best attempts of
trying to do that but he concludes that
it's not possible and he includes it
it's not possible for underlying logical
grounds that language cannot somehow
step outside of itself to catch sight of
the relationship to something that is
other than language it's got no way of
doing that and so that's where he ends
up now I however I don't buy uh Lincoln
Stein's conclusion that therefore we
should just give up on metaphysics
because
um uh he does hold a metaphysical
position in his later later uh uh uh
writing I would argue so that the only
way on we understand his writing like
the investigations is to impute to him a
an overall philosophical view namely
that we're wandering around in a
language game now that's a metaphysical
view it's to stand back and have seen
humans on the one side in this world of
language and the world somewhere else
and and and uh to have somehow described
How It ultimately is so I don't think
that vixenine really does carry through
on his on his claim to a abandon
metaphysics but
um but nevertheless I I think the
traditional note of notion of
metaphysics that existed pre the
linguistic turn uh we can't return to
and in that sense I think we have uh
forgotten some of those insights of the
linguistic turn precisely because it
leads us into a very difficult space
that's very interesting I suppose one of
the questions we will be exploring today
is what is metaphysics but um to begin
with our first theme now that we have a
guide to what your positions are
um we seem to use language to navigate
the world we find ourselves in yet many
argue language does not connect to the
world in any secure or concrete way in
fact as you said Ray wittgenstein's
tractatus explores that very question
what is the connection between language
and the world and Joanna would you like
to start with this one
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas